[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so on sky news coming up on today's
programme
cambo on pause is the controversial
north sea oil field dead in the water
after shells pull out
concern for species at the bottom of the
ocean as regulations to allow deep sea
mining come under consideration
and mcdonald's opens its first net zero
restaurant in the uk
but has to fend off accusations of
greenwashing
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the future of the controversial
cambo oil field project is in doubt
tonight after the company behind it
pressed the pause button it comes a week
after shell which had a thirty percent
stake in cambo walked away well today
the main developer sicar point energy
said it can't now go ahead on the
original time scale and it's evaluating
its next steps
critics have long argued that developing
north sea oil projects is incompatible
with the uk's aims to phase out fossil
fuels and achieve net zero
well despite those reservations news
began to emerge during the summer that
the uk was set to sign off on the new
oil field north west of shetland now
soon after
environmental activists started a
petition calling on the uk government to
block it
after previously saying it was a matter
for the westminster government
scotland's first minister nicolas
sturgeon then wrote to boris johnson in
august asking him to reassess cambodia's
license
a cop 26 at the beginning of november
the issue of whether cambodia should go
ahead was brought up repeatedly by
campaigners and politicians
at the end of last month ms sturgeon
told msps she didn't think the oil field
should be given the green light as it
wouldn't pass climate assessments now
this was the first time that the first
minister had publicly spoken out against
the project
then just last week shell announced that
it was pulling out of its 30
investment in cambo which led to today's
decision from the main developers sikkar
point energy that they're pausing work
on the project well skies aisha zaheed
is here with me now so aisha what does
this later step mean for the future of
the cambo project well the cambo oil
field has always been hugely
controversial and this decision to pause
the project means its future is looking
more uncertain but it doesn't write it
off completely sicar point energy the
firm behind the project say they they've
paused it to evaluate the next steps in
a statement they've said we continue to
believe cambo is a robust project that
can play an important part of the uk's
energy security providing homegrown
energy supply and reducing intensive
imports
reducing carbon intensive imports while
supporting a just transition
now the campbell oil field was widely
discussed at cop 26 by activists and by
politicians the hopes were it would help
create a secure homegrown energy supply
and jobs but activists raised concerns
that hundreds of ocean species would be
affected so this news is going to be
welcomed by all those campaigners in a
statement greenpeace said the economics
of the cambodia oil field were looking
decidedly shaky and the climate mass
never did make sense both the
westminster and scottish government now
need to end support for new oil and gas
infrastructure they should urgently
deliver a just transition to clean
energy providing the money policy and
training to ensure the communities who
have relied on the oil industry can move
to the green jobs of the future so the
future of the cambo oil field looking
uncertain but ultimately the final
decision will lie in the hands of the uk
government aisha thanks very much indeed
now the international seabed authority
has been meeting in jamaica this week to
discuss regulations which would allow
the mining of cobalt nickel and other
metals that could help the energy
transition towards renewables
their elements that are used to build
the batteries to power electric cars and
to store wind and solar energy
but despite the seemingly green
credentials marine biologists are
concerned about the impact on deep sea
biodiversity now one vast and as yet
unexploited resource is the deep sea bed
the ocean floor thousands of meters
under the water now one such area is the
clarion clipperton zone in the pacific
now the seabed there is some 4 000
meters below the ocean's surface now
that's as deep as some of the tallest
mountains in the alps are high now the
area holds trillions of poly metallic
nodules these are potato size deposits
loaded with manganese
cobalt and other precious oars
but while the minerals are valuable less
is known about the ecosystem at such
depths now many unknown species are
believed to live in the darkness and
recent studies have indicated that
mining the bed is likely to lead to
widespread biodiversity loss and
extinction
well dr diva amman is a leading marine
biologist deep sea mining expert and a
signatory to a letter signed by more
than 600 experts calling for a pause to
deep sea mining so welcome to you
i know that greenpeace has been
protesting against this just today but
what about you how worried are you about
the prospect of deep sea mining
yeah i'm very worried you know this is
an industry that if it moves forward
will create irreversible loss of
biodiversity and function i mean you're
going to be killing animals by grinding
them up on the seafloor especially as
many are actually attached to the
minerals that are being mined and it'll
create huge plumes of dust almost not
dust it'll create huge plumes that are
akin to toxic dust storms and noise and
light pollution on a scale never seen
before and this is a massive scale that
area the clarion clemson zone is the
size of the contiguous usa and this is
of course as you said already a part of
the planet that we know so little about
and is the closest to pristine
wilderness on earth and unfortunately
you know we currently have in my opinion
an inadequate and conflicted regulator
and a profound lack of science to really
move this industry or guide this
industry in the future
well yes tell us just how much we do
know then about the biodiversity at that
depth and and how important it could be
in mitigating against climate change how
much corbett carbon rather is stored
there
for example i mean presumably it's very
hard to do the research when it's so far
down
yeah absolutely i mean it's a really
tough place to do the research i mean
it's very different to walking around a
grassland or snorkeling on a coral reef
this requires time this requires
high-tech equipment and high levels of
expertise i mean often we will spend
months out at sea
plus many years in the lab after that
just to be able to understand you know
an area that is just a few square
kilometers so it's going to take likely
years if not decades to be able to have
the information that we may need to
manage this industry again if it does
move forward but you asked about the
biodiversity i mean
this is an incredible part of the planet
but one that you know we know so little
about i like to say that we have you
know a handful of pixels of information
if we consider the deep sea to be a
giant television screen you know and
it's not just
complex questions that we can't answer
it's the most basic questions that we're
talking about questions about you know
just what lives there how old do these
animals live to what role do they play
in these ecosystems
but we do know some things we know that
you know there are just hundreds of
thousands of species in the deep ocean
there are glowing sharks there are
snails that grow metallic armor and
there are corals that are amongst the
oldest animals on the planet living for
thousands of years
sorry to interrupt but just very quickly
those in favor of doing this will say
this is actually
good for the planet these are minerals
that can be really useful in batteries
for solar power for electric cars it's
worth doing
yeah so i think the question is at what
risk right this is a part of the planet
the deep sea is essential for keeping us
alive through climate regulation by
absorbing carbon and by absorbing heat
and sequestering carbon um there you
know we know that the ocean and the deep
ocean is already acting as a natural
buffer and helping to regulate our
climate and the deep sea mining will
unfortunately add much more stress to an
already stressed ocean and that could
push us to a tipping point where it
could cease to function as it already
does and that could mean limiting our
ability to deal with climate change in
itself well dr diva amman very
interesting to get your take on it
thanks very much indeed for joining us
today
thank you
now let's take a look at some of the
other climate stories making the news
today and an already delayed
biodiversity summit in china next spring
is under threat due to stricter
coronavirus travel restrictions nearly
200 countries are set to finalize an
agreement to safeguard plants animals
and ecosystems at the un conference
known as cop15 next may in the city of
kunming a rapid spread of the omicron
variant of covid19 could see
face-to-face talks delayed for a fourth
time
mcdonald's has opened its first uk net
zero restaurant the building is powered
by on-site solar panels and wind
turbines insulated with british sea
sheep's wool and cladded with recycled
i.t equipment and white goods
but some environmental campaigners have
accused the fast food chain of green
washing due to the amount of meat and
dairy on the menu a spokesperson for
mcdonald's says the restaurant was just
one of the many actions they're taking
as part of plans to achieve net zero
across their uk and ireland business by
2040.
the conservation group has announced it
plans to buy a stretch of northern
california coastline to protect it from
logging
save the redwoods league has agreed to
pay nearly 37 million dollars to buy the
land from a lumber company if it can
raise the funds by the end of the year
the
area is home to roosevelt elk and
mountain lions which live in the
forested hills along with endangered
species such as the northern spotted owl
and pacific fissure
now micro algae could play a significant
role in a future circular economy that's
because like trees algae can naturally
absorb carbon dioxide and turn it into
oxygen neutralizing harmful greenhouse
gas emissions now one brewery in sydney
australia has been working with
scientists by using algae to reduce
emissions from their fermentation
process but don't worry the algae
doesn't actually touch the beer
[Music]
no there's not algae in the beer the
beer the beer is unchanged the algae is
just part of the production process
never touches the beer
the co2 off the top of that beer
basically runs through the hose is
captured in this balloon
this balloon then feeds co2 into this
compressor where it's compressed
basically the co2 is then ingested by
the micro algae that uses it to
photosynthesize
that creates more algae
releases oxygen
algae capture co2
up to 400 times more efficiently than
tree it's just straight photo systems
capturing carbon and turning into
biomass so they're extremely efficient
they're they're probably the best
organism to trap carbon
to stay tuned coming up after the break
i'll be joined by lecturer in
international relations at cardiff
university jen allen and co-founder of
the cop 26 climate action plan chile oti
obihara and we're going to be discussing
the link between nature and climate
change and how best to call out
companies for green washing
the killer by design is the book that
tries to follow the history of the fbi
profilers
of how they would go to a crime scene
and be able to identify some of the
behavioral aspects that might lead to a
suspect and this work was really
profound because they um there was a lot
of push back then people didn't
understand necessarily what they were
doing but they
carried on they brought me in to try to
come up with a methodology if you will
where we could consistently look at 36
serial killers and try to identify
those characteristics that were unique
to them
where you start with that is at a crime
scene where you have a victim that's
really all you have so victimology or
the study of the victim is really what i
brought to their work because i have
worked with
rape victims here in boston
for about a year trying to understand
the the trauma that they went through
but also how the offender had dealt with
them so that was what i brought my
background being a nurse i was able to
identify those kinds of
behaviors that might be seen in the
crime scene
i was interested in the psychology of
patients and i became interested in
crime victims with my colleague who you
see on the screen linda lytle holmstrom
we were both new professors at boston
college and we wanted to study rape
victims the photo you see in there is
the team we believe strongly in the team
we had a research assistant we had a
detective we had a psychologist and you
had me as a psychiatric nurse we were
quite surprised to learn how early some
of these thoughts develop in the
the young child moving into adolescence
when they start acting out these
thoughts that was why i got into this of
how could we prevent more victims if we
could identify the behavior earlier and
and pay attention to it and get them
into treatment or some kind of safe
surrounding so that they wouldn't go out
and kill that's absolutely the whole
goal of the work
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
lecture in international relations at
cardiff university jen allen and
co-founder of the cop26 climate action
plan chidi oti obihara so very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
so first of all we spent much of the
year talking about the cop 26 climate
summit in glasgow which happened of
course last month but another u.n
meeting due to take place in kunming in
china is now in danger of being delayed
for the fourth time due to the rapid
spread of the latest covet variant
at stake is a deal to safeguard
ecosystems so are we in danger of
forgetting the importance of
biodiversity actually what do you think
how important is it that this kunming
summit goes ahead do you think
recruitment is is pivotal
the fact that it's been postponed again
uh even after it was made primarily
online last year kind of gives away the
impression that uh the ambitions that we
have the biodiversity have frankly
crashed through the floor
we can't allow the the broader issue of
how our ecosystems function to be
overshadowed by uh politics convenience
and a tendency to focus on the headline
issues of carbon rather than the broader
natural systems within
uh chile you're like your line just
throws that remote i'm going to move
over to jane but i will come back to you
and hopefully it will revive itself but
jen do you agree with that i mean the
world hasn't done brilliantly on meeting
biodiversity targets that were set in
japan in 2010 so how important is this
summit and what does need to be done
this summit is very important it's as
important as glasgow it's as important
as any other major meeting where
countries set rules for themselves that
they have to follow
they didn't do a great job the last time
they set rules and targets for nature
they didn't fully meet any of the
targets
so kunming is very important
it will go ahead it'll be postponed uh
partly because there was a meeting
that's supposed to happen before the cop
it was postponed because of worries
about omicron and there has to
procedurally be a bit of time between
that meeting and the cop so
could mean i think is still very much on
the card still going to happen it's just
a bit of a delay hopefully just for
procedural reasons and chilly expand a
little bit more on why you think it's
important to tackle both biodiversity
and climate change together
thank you very much for that
biodiversity is the broader picture it's
our ecosystem it's our home it's our
planet it's the very land we let stand
on the air we breathe the
decarbonization priorities of the cop
process are a subset of biodiversity
so if we don't get that biodiversity
right we can't get carbon uh uh
sequestration right in a new in a
holistic continuous and sustainable way
uh even though coptic
[Music]
the actual broader natural systems in
which we sit deserve just as much maybe
even more attention
chilly your system is teasing us we're
getting dramatic pauses occasionally but
we are getting the gist of what you're
saying jen very briefly and is it easier
in some ways for people to relate to the
whole nature issue
than climate change
i think so we walk through nature we see
nature we hear nature it's all around us
all the time
the climate system is invisible in a way
you know we sort of get inklings here
and there and hints that maybe climate's
changing but it's often in numbers and
models and figures
but nature we know you know we have a
deep connection with nature going back
to poetry and stories from our ancestors
way way back so
i think people do understand the need to
protect nature and they get behind that
sort of action
okay let's move on to our other subject
shall we because mcdonald's has opened
its first uk net zero restaurant today
but the chain which relies heavily on
meat and dairy has been accused of green
washing it says the restaurant is just
one part of its net zero plans but
whatever the merits of one company's
plans isn't the very fact that the
private sector is attempting to go
carbon neutral helpful for the planet so
chile let's talk very generally shall we
and should we be encouraged that
companies are increasingly wanting to be
part of the climate change conversation
and
want to be seen to be green
thank you very much for that well i
think the fact that so many large
companies
are very publicly pivoting towards net
net zero is an indication that we've won
the argument it's an indication that
environmentalists are being proven to
have been right all along
but
as they join our side of the argument
they need to be exact they need to have
plans that are functionally correct and
it's very very important that their
transition plans are managed by their
operations
not their marketing departments so
mcdonald's can have great adverts with
good-looking artists and beautiful young
children but if they don't take care of
their supply chain
if they don't make sure that they
responsibly source the things that we
eat if they don't make sure that they
don't encourage farmers to destroy the
ecosystems and farming us in
ways at the end of the day they still
contribute to the problem and that has
to change
jen would you agree with that i mean is
transparency at the heart of this and
how much do we have at the moment
we don't have much transparency at all
at the moment when it comes to net zero
plans especially by private corporations
there
it's very rare to see any sort of
published statements about what they're
including in their accounting how much
they're going to reduce their emissions
how much they're going to offset
and if a whole bunch of companies are
thinking of offsetting well that means
we're going to need countries the size
of brazil to just before us only for
company maybe like shell
so we need to know in terms of planning
what countries or what companies are
going to do
in order to have any hope of figuring
out if these net zero pledges are
realistic
so the secretary general has an effort
underway he announced at the glasgow
climate cop that he's going to bring
together some experts to start thinking
about what legitimate
net zero pledges and plans look like and
that could be a soft mechanism that
really would have a bit of teeth to it
in terms of all these companies using
the un as a platform to make these kinds
of announcements
judy finally do you have some optimism
that companies are moving in the right
direction
we are seeing a move in the right
direction but there are exceptions and
as jen very rightly pointed out shell
for example um we're focused on an op-ed
in the guardian just 48 hours ago where
they said the operational plans outlook
budget and pricing assumptions uh that
they had given the public didn't
not reflect their net zero plans so
we're in a world where corporations are
stating one thing and doing something
completely different and that's not
right what we need is an alignment
between the state of goals of these
corporations and their actual
operational actions
right chitty od obahara thank you for
for persevering even though your line
was a little bit dodgy but we got the
gist of all what you were saying and jen
allen thanks both very much indeed
well that's everything from us for this
week do stay tuned because coming up
next on sky news tonight new
restrictions in scotland where the first
minister warns of a tsunami of coveted
cases that's all coming up in the next
few minutes but do stay with us for the
daily climate show next week thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you